c'est qu'on doit faire envers nos draps
28 et c'est grâce au jambon mouffe mais
oui c'est à eux de leur faire payer les
gens qui regardent nous font vivre et en
plus on va leur demander de l'argent à
terre c'est pas bien c'est le minimum
qu'on l'ordre excusez moi si vous voulez
faire plaisir à une cousine qui adore
jennifer lopez vous n'avez pas les
coordonnées de jennifer lopez vous êtes
bien obligés de payer 75% pour l'artiste
et 25% mais non mais moi je trop
j'aurais adoré faire appel à ça quand
j'étais jeune je suis désolé ça ne me
choque pas ce qui me choque c'est que
magali soit choqué avec voilà ce que
après quoi après car si on me demandait
à un artiste deuxième anniversaire faire
plaisir vous tapez ans et pourrait les
influences aboudi dégueulasse pour ça
qu'il ya une différence entre placement
de produit ça le personnes produit tu
vend un produit du beau jeu et un
produit tu vas te servir à ton quotidien
oui mais c'est prendre enfin quand je
dis que c'est pas utiliser sensibilité
deschamps a brand et ça je trouve ça pas
gentil longtemps mais au contraire
daniel au 21e siècle une star connue sur
les réseaux a la possibilité de faire du
placement produit qui sont pas forcément
besoin de faire ça tu ne peux pas vivre
suffisamment sur les placements de
produits t'as pas besoin de vendre un
autographe et c'est pas correct ce que
tu dis tu peux pas me dire l'hôpital
s'appuie sur l'émission excuse moi c'est
quand les produits je suis déjà
dès qu'ils sont pleines les produits
mais parfois c'est de la merde là ça
fait plaisir
[Musique]
parfois d'escroquerie général mais ça
m'a choqué mais non armés ou des sites
est ce que moi j'ai choisi je rêve mais
les procès grenet il est contraint de
beaucoup de choses donc tu peux pas dire
ça aujourd'hui c'est jouer sa qualité
s'en ressent
[Musique]
la tension monte